le ciel
était trop rj
le moment tant redouté est venu
sort en est réellement de retour
j'en appelle à vous pour combattre avec
moi
les elfes et les nains travaillant main
dans la main le destin de la terre du
milieu est entre nos mains
nous pensions que la bataille
était désormais derrière nous
aujourd'hui
la paix se profile
nous pensions que nos joies jamais n'en
finirais
nous pensions que notre lumière jamais
c'est un prêt lesieux
petrov
[Musique]
galadriel pays de fine art in le moment
tant redouté
[Musique]
le mag ne dort jamais
ils patientent
dans les profondeurs la pénombre peut
tous nous engloutir sous la montagne
notre ami à bien des noms
tu as entendu parler de lui tu connais
le nom de sauron
cinémale qui s'élèvent en terre du
milieu n'est pas maîtrisée il va se
répandre et tous nous avertir
trouver la lumière est jamais l'ombre ne
trouveras
ensemble nous pouvons gagner
combattez avec moi
chacun d'entre nous se doit de décider
quel chemin il devra emprunter
ne peut y avoir de confiance entre un
marteau et une pierre
un
bonjour l'un ou l'autre on viendra se
briser
vous à compter tant de mensonges
sur la terre du milieu